victoria is in louisville kentucky to
start off
today hi victoria how can we help
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call um
i have uh just really complicated
situation i'm going to try to distill
down
to make the most of this call but
potential separation coming up
um with my husband he's active duty
military and he makes a good living and
i
work part time home school and uh
just facing just if we were to you know
um separate that you know we've been
making great traction together
and besides all the emotional stuff and
everything but i've got him on board
with
with you know dave ramsey and chris
hogan and and we've been
paying down almost 50 000 of debt in the
past three years and
basically i'll go down to just making
probably bill money
you know and i'm just wondering how i
can prepare
for that and we talked about maybe
staying together just for a financial
thing but like not
being you know he would be a
geographical bachelor i wouldn't pcs
with him anymore
so um just wondering what your advice
might be on
on that
[Music]
well i'm sorry i'm sorry you guys are
facing this
um i i would
number one if you're facing something
this serious you need to get a pro in
your corner
and that means you guys need to be
sitting down with a
a good strong marriage counselor who can
coach you guys through
how to make good wise decisions
um i didn't hear anything
just from a common sense perspective
healthy about you guys staying
uh married just for financial purposes
that's weird
yeah i thought so too yeah that just
sounds weird
that's just a guy talking i'm not a
professional but i mean it just
just sounds weird so um we still
love we love each other it's just he's
um
kind of like there's so many good things
but
um he's decided to
change genders so
i would love to say you know hey let's
be friends for the rest of our lives
that are married
but that just seems weird right yeah
yeah yeah yeah staying married in that
situation is going to be very strange
and so um you know i think someone
coaching you a good counselor can coach
you through how to set some
you know processes and boundaries in
place to
um you know to create a timeline
and then um even though this
sounds um yeah you said all the emotions
are there but it also sounds like you
guys are
uh just talking about this all still uh
in terms of uh you you've got a good
dialogue going it sounds like so that's
good
yeah but i i yeah but but even
in that good situation as in as good a
situation as it can be in a bad
situation
you um you you still once you
decide to divorce the transaction
changes to a business transaction right
and so and it doesn't mean you have to
be mean to someone because it's a
business transaction but you have to be
thorough and you have to think through
the math
uh like for instance he has an income
and you don't uh how much debt is left
whose name is on the debt is there a
house involved
you know all these kinds of things start
to be a business transaction that have
to be done on the very very
clear boundaries we see this a lot we
really do
and victoria one thing i want to suggest
and and by no me
by no way am i saying i'm a mayor's
therapist but at the same time
let's not prolong it you know let's have
a honest conversation like dave said
are we going to do this are we not and
once you decide what you're going to do
then you'll need to go down that path
with the right counsel
one thing i have seen is a lot of people
prolong this situation out and then it
gets worse and it gets worse down the
road
so have the conversation decide what
you're going to do
and once you get there immediately uh
seek out wise counsel
to walk you all through this step but i
got to say awesome job at least being
um kind to each other in the midst of
this process yeah
so in other words if if your name is on
a debt
and he is obligated to pay it in the
divorce decree
and does not they do not come after him
the divorce decree does not remove you
from liability you're still liable for
that debt
that's what i mean by a business
transaction you've got to sit down and
think about those kinds of things so
that these debts get
anything's got your name on it gets
cleared the second thing you've got to
do is you've got to get in ken coleman's
materials because you're going to
develop a career track
yeah uh part-time and stay-at-home mom
is not on your
not in your future anymore yeah you're
now a single mom
divorced and so what are you going to do
with your life and what's your career
look like what's your job look like and
you know you got to get on that really
fast because you're going to need an
income yes you're going to get child
support yes you may get some alimony
yes he may pick up a lot of the bills
but you've still got to create a
full-time income in this situation to
exist
and dave correct me if i'm rome but now
that that child becomes her number one
priority it's no longer
him sure yeah yes no i mean that would
be uh
yeah obvious but it was um
that is a way it has to go you know it
has to be that way
one of the things that i see anthony
that divorce attorneys make a huge
mistake on quite often
is um or couples do and the divorce
attorneys allow it to happen
just as a matter of transaction is
you know say a typical case study might
be
husband leaves the household okay they
get divorced
mom is left with the house and
most of the time has a lesser income
that's not
a statement of that's what she deserves
it's a statement of fact right
okay most of the time she has a lesser
income and can't afford the house
payment right
but is trying to hold on to the house to
keep it stable for the kids
and the house should have just been sold
yes and to get the bill off of her
she does not need that bill to go with
her new
res her new level of responsibility
financially that she's got to pick up
now
uh that's thing one thing two is that
from a husband's perspective
the lawyer tells him in that case in the
case where he's leaving the house
to her to quit claim the house
over to her give up his ownership
and they never address the fact that
he's still on the mortgage right
and so he's liable on the mortgage so he
gave up the asset and kept the liability
yes
and then he goes to buy another house
someday and he can't and he can't
because he already owns a house
as far as the debt goes yeah he's
already in debt on that other house he's
not been released from liability
so in that case i would you know if i
were going through that i would require
that the house either be sold or
refinanced and gotten out of his name
yes uh
in in that case to protect him and let
him go on with his life
and here's a hint if she can't afford to
refinance it that means she can't afford
to keep it
she needs to sell it that's right and
that's that's what you're facing it's a
it's a harsh
thing that occurs in a horrible
situation but there's a reality to this
math and it catches up with people
sometimes three years
later and they get a double whammy from
the divorce